翻訳: Kumika Moore
校正: Riaki Poništ
皆さん こんにちは
井庭です
今日 僕はここで 逆さになって
踊ったりしませんけども
皆さんに ちょっとしたアイデアを
紹介したいと思います
今日 どんな話をしようかというと
理想的な 自分たちの望む 豊かな
幸せな未来を実現する方法について
お話したいと思います
ちょっと魔法みたいですよね？
これ僕 今 研究をしていまして―
その研究をしている中で出てきたことを
ご紹介したいというふうに思うわけです
で
先端的な研究なんですけども
それ自体は難しいことは全然なくて
今日 家に帰ってから お父さん、お母さんと
子供でやることもできますし
もう 帰りの電車の中で することもできます
ま そういったことで
ただ とても重要なことなので
この場で皆さんと共有したいな
というふうに思っております
さて 今日の話
「未来を実現する」ということなんですけれど
「未来」―
「未来」というのは
「未だ来てない」というふうに
日本語では書きます
今を生きるっていうことは
とても大切なんですけれども
よくよく考えてみると
僕らは これから先は ずっと未来なので
毎日未来を生きていくということになります
これから死ぬまで 毎日毎日
新しく来る未来を生きていく
ということになるわけです
でも 僕らが普段 いろんな―
友達とか家族や会社の同僚
いろんな人と話しているのは
どちらかというと 未来の話というよりは
今の話であったり
過去の話であったりするわけです
そういう中で 未来について
考えることはとても大切で
未来について考えるとき
この言葉をいつも思い出します
アラン・ケイという人の言葉なんですけれども
「未来を予測する最善の方法は
それを自ら『つくる』ことである」
そういう言葉です
これは 放っておいても
今から寝て明日を迎えても 明日は来ます
未来は来るんですね
でも そうやって傍観者のように
自分と関係なく どっかから未来が
やってくるということではなくて
「自分が自分らしく未来を作っていく」
そういうことが重要だということが
このメッセージに込められているわけです
この人は「パーソナルコンピューターの父」
と言われていまして
僕らが今 家でパソコンを
使ったりしてますね
個人でパソコンを使っているというのは
何十年前にはありえなかった光景です
コンピューターは部屋ぐらい大きくて
軍事の目的だったりとか
科学計算のために使われていた
で その時代に これからは
コンピューターを一人一人が持って
そして そのコンピューターを使って
表現をしたり
あるいは何か 勉強をしたり
そういったことをしていく時代になるんだと
コミュニケーションをしたり
そういったことをしていこう
そういうためのコンピューターの
利用があるんだということを言って
それを実現してきた一人
ということになるわけです
で 僕らは「社会を変える」っていうと
大きな話になってしまいますが
例えば 「自分がこれから将来
どういうふうに生きていくのか」
あるいは「自分たちの家族が
どういうふうあったら幸せなのか」
そういったことを考えて
作っていくというのは
僕たち一人一人が
やってかなきゃいけないことになるわけです
で 自分たちの関わり次第で
いい方向にも行ったり 悪い方向に行ったり
イマイチな方向に行ったり
そういうことになるわけですね
なので僕らは その自分たちの
より良い幸せな未来に向かって
何ができるかということを日々考えて
実践しているということになるわけです
ただ「幸せ」というものが
どうもボヤっと
まあ みんな幸せな未来になりたいですよね？
幸せになりたいですよね？
でも「幸せ」って何かってのは
人それぞれ違いますし
それぞれ時期によっても違うかもしれません
で とても曖昧なモヤっとしたものに
なっているはずです
あるいはそれを どこからか出てきた
キャッチコピーやスローガンのようなもので
一言で言ったとしても それはちょっと
一部しか言っていないような
ことになってしまうと
なので そのモヤっとしていて曖昧なものを
一人で実現する時も
やはりそれは難しいですし
それを例えば「家族みんなで作ろう」とか
あるいは自分たちの友達同士
「グループで作ろう」
もしくは「地域で作ろう」「会社で作ろう」
そういったことをしている場合には
自分たちのその先にある 未来にある幸せが
どんなものかということを考えて
実現していかなきゃいけないと
だけども 曖昧なので
これが みんなそれぞれ
ちょっとずつ違った所を考えていたり
違うようなイメージを持っていると
だんだんなんか上手くいかなくなってきて
話が合わなくなってきて
「いや そういうことじゃないだろう」とか
「どうして こういうことが幸せなのに
してくれないんだ」っていうようなことで
ケンカになってしまったりとか
あるいは 上手くいかなくなってしまう
実現できなくなってしまうってことが
よくあるわけです
そこで 今日僕が皆さんと共有したい方法
アイデアというのは
「どのような未来が幸せなのか」ということを
言葉にしようということです
言葉にするだけですので 今日 家に帰っても
電車でもできますっていう話ですね
何の道具も要りません
話して 自分で考えて話していけばいい
ということになるわけです
そうすると 一つの言葉じゃなくて
たくさん いくつも言葉を作ります
「こういう未来がいいよね」
「こういうことが幸せだよね」
ってことを言葉にすると
そしてそれを 話の中でみんなで
その言葉を作って それを共有すると
そういった未来にある 先にある
まだ来ていない幸せが
どういうものなのかっていうのの
イメージが共有できるようになります
もちろん 絵が得意な人は
絵で描くのもいいでしょう
あるいは 何か違う表現でするのも
いいと思います
でも 言葉というのは
何の道具も要らずに話の中で
普通に会話の中で使うことができますし
ずっと記憶の中に留まって
それをずっと持ち運ぶことができます
なので 今日お話ししたような言葉
「幸せの形に名前を付ける」
ということになります
で ちょっとこう抽象的に言っても
イメージがつかないかもしれないので
うちの家族でですね
子供に「どんなときに幸せか」
と訊いてみました
まあ ポイントはですね
未来の言葉を作るポイントは
どんなときが幸せかということを
自分に問うてみたり
一緒にいる人に問うてみたりする
訊いてみる
そういうとこから始まります
で うちにいる子供たちに
「どんなときが幸せ？」と訊いてみました
そうすると いくつか出てきます
「みんなで買い物してるときは楽しいな」と
普通に家の近くのスーパーに行くわけですけど
その中で買い物しているときは
楽しいという答えがきました
「ああ そうなんだ」と
「そうなんだね」と
で「ドライブに出かけているとき」
なんかこれは
僕はちょっと想像していましたが
みんなでどこか旅行に行ったり
近くの所で遊びに行ったりする
「それは楽しいね」と
あとは「パパも一緒にテレビを見ているとき」
という答えが返ってきました
これは 僕は普段 夜も含めて
あちこち研究や活動をしているので
なかなか一緒にテレビを見る時間ってのは
限られているんですけども
そういう時間が幸せなんだということを
改めて訊いてみて 知ることができました
こういったことをよく見てみると
共通点があるんじゃないかな
ということですなんですね
今回これで見て僕が感じたのは
「家族で一緒に」いるっていうこと
一緒に何かをするってことは
すごく幸せだというふうに
子供たちが感じているんだなと思いました
で 僕もそう思います
なので「家族と一緒」っていう
言葉を作りました
そうすると これから何かをしようか
今週の土曜日 日曜日
何しようかっていうときに
「家族と一緒に何かをしよう」ってことが
発想ができて
そういうことを思いついて それを提案したり
話し合ったりすることができるわけです
もちろん 「家族の幸せ」ってことは
それだけに留まらなくて
もっと色々話していくとですね
「楽しい場所」に行ったりすると
それは幸せだよねとか
「おいしいもの」を食べてるときは
幸せだねとか
「新しい発見」
何か本を読んだり いろんな何かを見に行って
新しい発見があるときも幸せだねと
こういったような
いくつかの要素で成り立っている
いくつもの要素で成り立っている
なので 一個だけ
例えば「家族で一緒」だけでいいんだ
ということではなくて
楽しい場所もあれば
新しい発見のときもある
それが同時に起きることもあれば
別々の日に起きることもある
でも そういったことの総体が全部まとめて
「幸せ」ということを形作っていると
こういう言葉を作ろうということです
これが「幸せのかたちに名前をつける」
「幸せ」というのは
三角形であるとか四角であるとか
一言で言えるわけではないんですね
なので いろんな言葉 いろんな側面から
その幸せを自分たちで言葉にして
自分たちで定義をしていくということです
ここ見てわかる通り
ここに出てきた言葉っていうのは
ある種 当たり前というか
そんなに特殊なことは書いていません
でも これを自分たちで作った
ということに価値があります
自分たちの幸せの言葉の辞書は
自分たちで作るしかありません
なので 自分たちで作って
それを自分たちで使っていく
そういったことが未来に向かって 自分たちの
幸せな未来を作っていく大切な一歩なんです
幸せのかたちに名前をつけられることが
自分たちの幸せな未来を作る
大きな一歩となるということになります
で 僕は研究で こういったことを
しているというお話をしましたが
今 家族の例ですが
例えば 自分たちらしく生きていくためには
「自分たちらしさ」って何だろう
「自分たちの幸せ」って何だろう
「自分の幸せに感じること」
「大切に思ってること」って何だろうって
みんなで考えて
話し合っていく中で
自分らしさを見つけていく
そういうワークショップを開いています
これ 先週 東京でやった
ワークショップなんですが
中学生ぐらいから大人まで参加して
みんなで自分たちらしさを
自分で自分のことを考えるんですけども
その途中で いろんな人と話しながら
それをまとめていく
そういうワークショップです
その一週間前には
僕はブラジルにいました
ブラジルというと
ちょうど地球の反対側ですね
日本の反対側です
ブラジルで同じように
ワークショップをしました
ちょうど夏なんですけれども
もっと大人たちが
「自分たちらしさ」って何だろう
「自分が大切にしているもの」
「幸せ」って何だろうということを考えて
こういうふうに
まとめたりもしています
これ「自分たちらしさ」なんですね
その他にも 自分たちの理想とする
幸せな未来っていうのは
自分たちの中の大切にしているもの
だけではなくて
例えば オフィス―
自分たちが働く会社の環境が
どんなふうな環境が良いだろうかってことも
話し合って作ったりもします
これは実際にオフィスで働いている皆さんが
どういうオフィスが幸せなんだろうか
自分たちの理想なんだろうか
ということを話して
この右下のオフィスができたんですけども
こういった形で 自分たちの理想の
場を作るということをしています
あるいは 今 新しいカフェを
作ろうとしていまして
カフェを利用する人やその供給をする人
そういう人たちとみんなで
どんなカフェが
理想なんだろうってことを考えて
その理想的な幸せなカフェを作る
ということもやっています
これ来年オープンします
その他 フューチャーセンターというのが
最近色々な所にあるんですけれども
「未来を考えよう」っていう場が
いろんな地域に出来始めています
そのいろんな地域で出来始めている
フューチャーセンターという所で
例えば これは農業の未来―
その地元の農業をどうやって良くしていくか
ということを農家の方々と話していたり
ママさんたちが自分たちの
子育てをしながら働く そういった未来は
どんなようなあり方があるだろうってことを
話し合って それも言葉にしています
それぞれ農業も
60個ぐらい新しい造語ができて
未来を語るための言葉ができましたし
働き方―
子育てしながら働くという生き方についても
50、60ぐらいの言葉ができてきます
こういうことを研究でやってるわけです
これは他にも海外で 自分たちの
専門的な分野の発展を
どうやってやってくかという未来図を
みんなで描くということを
これは９月にアメリカでやったものですが
こういった形で言葉にしていくと
この時も30、40の言葉ができて
早速この日から その一個の言葉を
実践しようということで
右下にいる彼が かっこよくてですね
「未来は今から始まるんだ」と言って
その日から実践をし始めたこともあります
こういうふうに 自分たちがどういうものを
理想とするのかっていうのは
意外と語ってないんですね
あるいは 考える時間てのが
なかなか無くて
目の前の問題を解決するとか
過去の色々なことから勉強しようとか
そういうことが多くて
なかなか自分たちで自分たちの未来を
「こうしていきたい」
「こういうのが理想だよね」
「こういうことが幸せだよね」
っていう時間ていうのは
なかなか日常の中ではありません
そういう機会が少ないんです
なので 話す時間を作り
それを言葉にしていくと
言葉にすると みんながそれを理解して
それを共有して 話し合って
そして明日も明後日も
それを覚えておくことができるということです
これが今日 僕がお話ししたかったことです
そうすると何がいいかということも
最後 まとめておきたいんですね
曖昧な未来のイメージが
曖昧なままではなくて
５つや10個の言葉で
成り立つようになるので
そうすると その言葉を使って
未来のイメージを形作っていくことができると
で そのイメージを作れば それに向かって
みんなで動いていくことができるし
何をしたらいいかっていうことを
考えることができます
そして２つ目
覚えておきやすくなる
言葉なので
すごく簡単な「家族と一緒」「家族で一緒」
って言葉は簡単に覚えられます
難しい専門用語は何もありません
自分たちで作る言葉なので
自分たちで覚えておくことができます
そして 他の人と共有して
話すことができるようになります
言葉なので いつでもどんな時でも
カフェでもご飯を食べながらでも
いつでもしゃべることができる
使うことができる
そういったことが このメリット
ということになります
最後にですね 大人の事例が続いたので
最後に子供たちの話なんですけれども
僕の知り合いの
東京コミュニティスクールという所で
子供たちが学んで いろんなことを
面白いことをやってるんですね
プロジェクトをやって 自分たちなりに
何か生み出していくことをしている学校です
この中で彼らが自分たちが
大切にしているものをまとめました
それが『THE こども力』という小冊子に
手描きで作った冊子で
まとめられているんですけど
この中から２つ紹介したいんですね
一つは「ねじれても広がる」というものです
これは いろんなアイデアを
出していくときに なんか話がねじれて
なんか上手くいかなくなってるかのように
感じるんだけど そこから広がりが出てくる
単にパッと思いついたアイデアではなくて
ちょっとぐちゃっとなった所からが
始まりだということを
彼らは「ねじれても広がる」
という言葉で表現しました
これが彼らが大切にしていることの一つだと
彼らは自分たちが小学生の時に体験したことを
これから大人になってもずっと
「ねじれても広がる」っていうことを
大切にしながら生きていけますし
また大人になったら もうちょっと違う表現に
変わってくるかもしれませんが
こういったものを持っていくことができます
あるいは「変なのがいい」と
これ僕 大好きなんですけども
「変なのがいい」
普通にただ「普通」と
「そうじゃないか」を考えたときに
変だと ちょっと嫌だなとか
変じゃなくて普通がいいと思いがちだけども
実は「変」っていうのは 単に
「普通じゃない」だけじゃなくて
とても新しかったり
面白かったりする可能性があると
なので ギャグみたいな形で
変だっていうことではなくて
もうちょっと
「普通とは違う発想をすること」を
むしろ僕たちは大切にしてるんだ
ってことを表現したわけです
これも同じように やはり
自分たちが大切にしている未来
自分たちの大切にしていること
それを言葉にした例だということになります
ということで
今日僕がお話したかったこと
今日 ぜひ家に帰る途中でも
帰ってからでもいいんですけれども
「どんなときが幸せか」ということを
自分自身で考えてみたり
家族や同僚、友達と
話してみてほしいと思います
「どんなときが幸せか」と
で 「どんなときが理想」で
「何が良いと思っているのか」
「どんなことを大切にしているのか」
そういったことを
まず話し合うことから始めて
それを言葉にするということです
幸せのかたちに名前をつける
一つの名前ではなくて たくさんの側面に
一つ一つに名前をつけていく
この名づけるということは とても大切で
僕らの大体持っている辞書には
いろんな物の名前
あるいは 形容詞はたくさん持ってます
動詞はあります
でも自分たちの夢や理想
そして幸せというものには
あんまり言葉がないんですね
日本語も英語もそうでしょう
そういったことを自分たちで自分たちの
未来に向かう辞書を作っていく
それが僕が今日 皆さんに紹介したい―
広める価値があるアイデア
ということになります
ぜひ自分に何が幸せなのか問うてみて
ぜひ家族、友達とも
話してみてほしいと思います
以上です
どうもありがとうございました
（拍手）